[music]
Thank you everyone. I'm Eric. I'm one of
the co-founders of Encord. Encord is a
data layer for physical AI. So we work
in all different types of physical AI in
robotics, autonomous vehicles, drones,
manufacturing, logistics, etc. And
what's very exciting about where we are
is that we get to see the frontier of AI
in the real world across many many
different domains. But I personally
didn't start there. Originally I started
uh in physics. So my background was in
particle physics. I was doing research
there and one of the great particle
physicists is Murray Galman and he has a
quote that's always stuck with me which
is everything that that's not forbidden
is compulsory.
So what this says is that in particle
physics if physics says it's not
prohibitive it not only can happen it
will happen.
So I've taken this forward in starting
an AI company, a technology company and
it's worth thinking about uh what in AI
is forbidden and what is compulsory.
So we're currently on a trajectory in AI
um to what Dario Mod says will be a
country of geniuses in a data center. So
what problems will this country of
geniuses be able to solve?
Well, you take this country of geniuses,
this superelligence and you put it in a
box and it will solve the greatest
mathematical puzzles of our day. So, I'm
sure it'll prove or disprove the Reman
hypothesis. It'll be great at
literature. So, it'll bring it'll write
poetry. That will bring even stoic
technologists to to tears. It'll be a
better developer than all of us. It'll
win every coding competition.
But this super intelligence in a box, it
won't be able to learn how to ride a
bike. So this is a demonstration of of
Moravex paradox.
And if you spend a lot of time in the
Bay Area, which which I do, a big
question is will is the trajectory that
we're on going to bring us to AGI,
right? And AGI is a it's a very abused
term. Um, but I think it can be useful.
However, this question is the wrong
question. It's not if the trajectory
that we're on will bring us to AGI. It's
which AGI will it actually bring us to
because AGI will actually happen twice.
It'll happen once in the digital world
and once in the physical world. And
digital AGI is AI systems that will
command and control all of our
information systems. So everything that
we see now with the scaling of LMS that
will bring us to digital AGI. But I
think a much more interesting and a much
more compelling vision of the future
will be in physical AGI where AI systems
command and control the actual physical
world around us. And this will will be
what takes us from the society that we
live in today to a society of science
fiction to one that we can't even
imagine.
But digital AGI will happen first. Okay.
So why will it happen first? Well, there
are three core concepts, three blockers
uh which I put into three equations that
we need to satisfy before we get to
physical AGI.
So we'll go through the three equations.
They're kind of huristic demonstrations
of what we need to conquer before we get
to this um you know immense vision of
the future.
So first equation,
this equation is probably the most
important equation of the decade. Uh
literal trillions of dollars of economic
activity are sitting on the back of this
equation. It's probably the thing that's
propping up the entire global economy.
I'm talking about the chinchilla scaling
law. Um so it's a pretty simple equation
that I'm sure most of you know. There's
only four terms. There's the loss term
which very roughly speaking is the kind
of accuracy rate of the model. The lower
the loss, the smarter the model. There
is an entropy term which we can't do
anything about. So we will just ignore.
But then there are two terms that we can
do something about. One is the scale
term. So this is this n as the model
scale increases the loss goes down as a
power law of that scale. And then
there's the data term. So as data
increases the loss also goes down as a
power law of the data. All right. This
equation was empirically derived about
uh half a decade ago and is the implicit
assumption behind hundreds of billions
of dollars of capex spend now in AI.
What does this tell us about physical
AI? This is for pre-training of LMS. Um
why is this relevant?
Well, one uh we are starting to see
actual scaling laws in physical AI. um
which is quite exciting uh with the the
work of of NVIDIA and others. But I
think this equation is a great
demonstration of the immense head start
that digital AI has had compared to
physical AI because they have what I
call the great data subsidy.
300 trillion tokens of free data that
was compiled organically over decades on
the internet. Tens of millions of books,
basically all of human written language
was there almost for free for these
models to ingest and establish a base
level of intelligence.
And unfortunately, physical AI does not
have the same luxury. There is no
internet level scale of data that we can
use to train in these physical AI
systems. The largest robotics data set
is uh 270,000 hours. It's about
equivalent to my lifetime. So that's one
person's lifetime versus all of human
written language for LMS.
But uh there is a lot of video of the
physical world, right? There's the
YouTube data set which doesn't even fit
on the slide. It's like uh the size of
the sun. So uh why can't we just learn
from that? Well, physical AI now it
can't just learn purely from the pixels.
Digital AI has the uh luxury of having
the same substrate of prediction and
training. It's tokens in and tokens out.
Whereas physical AI systems, they
actually have to act in the real world.
They have actuators and sensors.
But now there's a lot of this work in
world models that that should solve this
problem, right? The solve the data
problem. Well, this brings us to our
second equation.
So uh what does chaos theory tell us
about physical AI? So equation maybe uh
not everyone knows is the leapun
exponent equation.
This is for small perturbations in
initial conditions for certain systems
they can grow exponentially in time. So
that means um small differences in
initial conditions they will have vastly
different global trajectories.
So this is the uh the butterfly effect,
right? A butterfly flaps its wings in
Japan and six months later there's a
hurricane in Florida.
So it this also exhibited in pretty
simple physical systems. The double
pendulum, right? A single uh pendulum is
a problem that a first year physics
student can just solve in a classroom
their first semester. But you add one
more mass to it and suddenly you get
completely chaotic unpredictable
behavior which you cannot uh condense
into a set of parsimonious equations.
Reality itself is incompressible
and what's more is that small errors
because of the leaponov exponent
equation they compound exponentially in
time. So if you get a small error in
measurement wrong that will lead to a
very large error in the future and
models models are filled with errors.
Models are approximations. Uh every
model is wrong. Some models are useful.
So a world model that has these
approximations for these chaotic
systems. They are by definition wrong.
They will be much more wrong in time for
these chaotic systems. which means world
models can never fully capture the
physical world. This is um just thinking
about the chaos of the real world. Does
that mean world models are completely
useless? No. Um it just mean well first
I'm talking about physical AGI so
general intelligence across all physical
systems. The second is that world models
will be necessary but not sufficient.
What you need to complement is continual
measurement to actually reflect reality
because these small errors will lead to
large errors. You need to continuously
ping the real world to ground back to uh
the the actual real state. So we need
physical grounding for these systems to
actually work. We need actuators. We
need sensors. Physical AI cannot live in
your head. Digital AI can. All right. So
why don't we just deploy a bunch of
physical AI systems into the real world?
Well, this brings us to our third
equation uh which is the societal risk.
This is used by uh nuclear safety
regulators. It's used in the EU. Uh what
does this equation tell us? There's
three terms. There's the f term, so the
frequency of a failure happening.
There's n which is the number of people
harmed in that failure. There's C which
is some societal threshold and there's
alpha which is the societal risk
aversion and in practice regul
regulators tend to set alpha to two
which means that for an event that harms
two people it should happen at one
quarter of the time of an event that hap
that hurts one person. So for an event
that hurts 10 people it should happen
100th of the time. These things are not
linear they're quadratic.
Which the bad news for physical AI is
that this N term per air is much higher
than in digital systems.
So uh physical systems they're on our
roads. They're drones above our head.
They actually have the ability to
properly harm us if they aren't uh
controlled properly. And what the
societal risk criterion says is that the
physical AI system reliability needs to
scale quadratically with the failure. So
quadratically against digital AI
systems. And you can see this
subjectively in um how this manifests.
Uh digital AI failures, they they go
into memes and LinkedIn posts. Uh
physical AI failures, they literally
make headlines. And I was at a picnic
recently and I was talking about Whimo
and how great Whimo was. And the person
uh at the picnic, the only thing they
knew about Whimo was the time that it
drew drove through a um an active crime
scene.
Compared to Adams, bits are cheap, bits
are more predictable and bits are safer.
So does does this mean uh so AGI will
type before it walks? So does this mean
that physical AGI is impossible?
uh physical AGI there's a lot of work
being done in architecture and
algorithms in hardware and control
systems but the scaling laws tell us
that there's actually a very simple
answer there's a very simple recipe
which is the data and importantly closed
loop systems with the data so you need
models to go out act measure and learn
and you need to do this continuously
simulation will be a complement to this
process
But what chaos theory tells us is that
simulation is not sufficient. You need
these AI systems to actually be out in
the real world and learn continuously.
This is what we do at Encord. We've
worked with hundreds of teams to build
this loop. And what we find from our
experience is that the uh the cycle time
the iteration cycle is proportional to
the probability of the AI system
actually being successful. So the faster
that this loop is the more likely that
your AI will actually work.
And the good news is that there's
enormous progress that's being made in
this field. Now with robotics, some of
them here, these things are actually
starting to get into the real world in
production and um creating these closed
loop data systems.
And what's very exciting for me in
particular with that uh is that robotics
is actually um it's not the endgame for
physical AI. We might be um uh
converging to the endgame of robotics,
but robotics is just the beginning of
physical AI. It's the bellweather. It's
the canary in the coal mine. This is the
proof of concept of us building physical
systems that can continuously interact
and learn with the physical world.
That's actually what we're looking for.
If this works in robotics, then this
opens up the floodgates to all other
physical systems that uh that we work
with. So physical AGI what this will
mean is that it will mean complete
disruptions and transformations in every
physical system that we know about in
chemistry in biology, in engineering, in
aerospace, in scientific discovery.
This will completely transform our world
in ways that we cannot imagine. We'll
get to digital AGI and that will be
great, but physical AGI will be what
takes us to Star Trek to science fiction
and above. I can imagine a world where
there's swarm intelligence that
optimizes all the energy efficiency of
every building and all the traffic and
there's 3D printers that instantiate any
type of object uh buildings within
minutes, right? This is the dream that
physical AI AGI um can bring us. And it
sounds far-fetched, but 10 years ago
talking to a robot uh in a conversation
that also sounded far-fetched.
So physical AGI will bring us to this
dreamed of a prompt to reality. You have
an idea and you can actually instantiate
it in the real world.
So that's the dream. That's the type of
AGI that I'm looking forward to. one
where there brings human abundance,
prosperity, wealth, welfare, uh health
care, everything if we do this right.
But there is one more equation uh to to
walk through which is that happiness is
reality minus expectations.
And now there's quite a lot of
excitement and energy um and hype in
physical AI which is bringing this
expectations term up. And the only way
for us to stay happy or to get happier
is if we also work on the reality term.
We have to bring that up faster than our
own expectations. And that means being
realistic about the uh the bottlenecks
that we're seeing in these physical AI
systems. So the bottlenecks in data in
chaos and unpredictability and
measurement and risk. But we can solve
these things. And I'm 100% confident
that we will solve it and that we will
bring physical AGI. And why is this?
Well, all the equations that I went
through, they showed why it's hard, not
why it's impossible. And again,
everything that's not forbidden is
compulsory. Physical AGI is coming.
Thank you. I'm Eric. Uh, thanks
everyone.